who were some of the first big names
that message you to say hey man we
support you keep at it we got your back
where you said we're not alone or a lot
of people it is in Hollywood they
unfollow me immediately yeah never heard
from them again yeah yeah well the black
ones anyway
[Laughter]
but did you get did you when you said
you started getting support I mean that
was a name where you said wow this guy
supports us pro football players from
the Dallas Cowboys um pro baseball
players
um any political commentators any
political comments like did did you hear
from Larry Elder did you hear from
bongino did you hear from Candace did
you hear from any of these guys at the
time of course we know everybody knows
who you are I'm just saying at the time
they were they didn't reach out
personally but they were retweeted I
guess that's a form of support yeah yeah
so
um
but uh it as far as the whole Uncle Tom
stuff that really stems from uh you know
black people think
um as a black person you have to vote
Democrats so they're not actually
thinking with their mind using their
brain when they vote they think what
their skin color so when they see me
vote for Republican they start to
project and think I'm voting for
Republicans because I love white people
I want to be white or I want to have
white friends or white girlfriends
that's this dumb [ __ ] I hear but it has
nothing to do with race while we're
Republican yeah black people have not
realized why I'm Republican has nothing
to do with my race yeah I understand why
you vote Democrats because you're black
and you think
um you think people Democrat Party on
your vote yeah Joe Biden thinks it too
he said if you don't vote for me you're
not black I mean I get that but that's
not why I'm Republican it has nothing to
do with race it has everything to do
with freedom and I'm living my life so
so so Keith Kevin yes by the way I'm
starting to realize the difference if I
assume yeah immediately no you got a
different smile than he's got it's all
in the eyes I this is how I tell you
guys Apart Nothing More not color the
eyes but the eyes of a different look
okay but but Keith question for you so
um you know for you what you say I don't
understand it's common sense to be a
conservative right I don't even know how
somebody could be a Democrat today so
okay there's a lot of people on the
other side that have fancy degrees that
are very well off that are financially
well off some of them are billionaires a
lot of them are billionaires you can't
tell me they're they're dummies to be
they're not dummies why do you think
they're Democrats what makes what do you
think why do you think they're Democrats
well first of all they're successful
because they're in the greatest country
in the world okay first and foremost
um the reason why they're Democrat is
did not think in wrestling they're not
thinking logically they're not lose
using like at all I don't see how
anybody could support the Democratic
party with that policy how would they
become billionaires because then to
become become very successful in life
right you have to be able to reason
and to be able to stretch a dollar you
have to be able to hire the right people
you have to be able to put systems
together to raise Capital you you know
you you have to you have to do a lot of
those things to be able to succeed
regardless where you are politically
what why do you think these people still
Democrats use emotion to gain votes just
like what happened in uh Georgia they're
trying to change around the voting yeah
um they want voter ID how did the
Democrats spend that they call it Jim
Crow this is racism they actually moved
to Major League Baseball game out of um
Atlantic Georgia to Colorado they use a
motion for boats once you can grab
somebody emotionally they stop thinking
tell a black person somebody's racist oh
that's all they need to hear that's it
you don't have to use logic to know
racism and bad so when they hear that
they believe it yeah I think a majority
of billionaires are are liberal because
they don't think for the uh little man I
mean if I'm a billionaire the first
thing I I don't see why any billionaire
would want to be a conservative to begin
with because to be a conservative man
you think about everybody as far as a
billionaire doesn't mean you just
because you're billion and you're a
rational or logical thinker oh you're
thinking about all you have for the most
part is great ideas
for a business you you put out a great
idea and it and everybody gravitates to
towards it and that's how you can you
can earn lots and lots of money then
based on ideas does that mean the so
let's let's let's identify it as that so
at this point you know I'm by the way
I'm playing the devil's Advocates I'm
just trying to enjoy a good debate here
so let's identify the fact that people
who are billionaires they're great at
being creative and coming up with the
best ideas does that also mean that the
left has given them better ideas to bind
to to vote for because they're attracted
by their ideas because look it's either
messaging it's either delivery of
messaging it's either that's exactly so
what's how you deliver your message okay
how you present your message Democrats
yeah are actually better politicians
than Republicans yeah
Republicans rely on the proof to push
out their message
Democrats play politics yeah they do a
lot of and hominin attacks they do a lot
of things that you know intellectuals
should not do in any civil debate they
say things they call people like racism
as a black man the first thing when I
heard somebody say somebody's racist I
didn't even double check it I
automatically assume that they're racist
because I was trauma because ever since
I was a young age so whenever I see a
Democrat say the other side is racist
they're being intellectually dishonest
because they already know for black
people
when he hit that word you're traumatized
do you think that's why so okay so now
we now we're getting to a point of
they're able to tap into the emotional
side Republicans are kind of like this
the truth how do you not understand it
this is logical you know right but you
know the whole thing about facts tell
stories sell you know Republicans are
trying to solve facts and people like
you're not emotional so you go going
back to the whole thing with the
emotional side okay so I'll tell you
like this Patrick uh Democrats they
um sale victimhood yeah nobody wants to
be able to like Republicans it's all
about pull yourself up by your
bootstraps you know as far as when it
comes to Democrats they like to sell
victimhood it's very hard to convince
somebody that you are the problem like
it's not your government it's not
Society it's not racism your life is
based on the ideas you come up with
in-house nobody likes that yeah nobody
wants to hear it and that's all very
hard sale that's a very hard sell very
good point yeah everybody wants to hear
oh it's not my fault it's the government
that's all my fault it's racism that's
why
um I mean as far as being a Democrat
they do have
you know they have it a lot easier when
they presenting their messages because a
lot of these things that they share with
people about racism uh transphobia all
these things the majority of them are
just made up terms to divide everybody
so they can grab your vote they could
care less about Society if you ask me a
demo so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
[Music]